I've come to see the market and the free
society generally is actually much more
robust and Hardy than I once believed it
to be hey it's Kennedy for reason TV
today we're talking with Donald J
Boudreaux he's a professor of economics
at George Mason University he also blogs
for a cafe Hayek and he has a new book
out in July it's called hypocrites and
half-wits Don is a letter writer of the
highest order and this is a publication
of some of your finest angriest letters
when did you become a letter writer
about 15 years ago I was president of
the foundation for economic education
and I always did write a lot of letter
to the editor and I thought with email
now I can send out my letters to the
people that I raise money from so they
can see that I'm on the job and it sort
of snowballed from there and you're kind
of a constitutional sharpshooter well
it's one of the things I do my friend
Dwight Lee calls me a sniper and I kind
of like that kind of like that term you
I see a thing in the news every day or
two and you let go and do you get
responses from editors and writers yeah
about four percent of the letters
actually get published in the
publication's in New York Times
Washington Post most of them are just
published on my blog and now some of
them in the book but i do get feedbacks
from them sometimes sometimes it's angry
sometimes it's they're thanking me for
correcting a misconception that they had
and then they realized someone's out
there really watching and maybe it makes
them better at their job I hope so now
you say in the book that for years your
family has not allowed you to wear shoes
watching TV you've had to remove your
loafers and sneakers because you would
throw them at the tube that was a threat
and and if you watch keeping up with the
kardashians do you think you would beat
yourself to death with your own clogs I
probably would yeah and and then
suffocate myself under the cushion you
know now it's not so much TV it used to
be the evening news when I started
watching dan Rather and Tom Brokaw now
it's just blogs and the New York Times
and The Washington Post there's never a
shortage of economic ignorance to take a
shot at letter writing has always been
very effective from the Zodiac killer to
the Unabomber to penthouse forum what do
you hope to accomplish
I writing your letters seriously the
main goal is to hopefully attract young
people who aren't yet familiar with the
economic way of thinking and to make a
clear concise in many cases hopefully
humorous point about how powerful
economic way of thinking can be and to
expose just you know common
misconceptions that that forever in the
press and muscle my it's my main goal is
to show people that look economics is
not that difficult at least you know
basic basic economic way of thinking it
can be expressed clearly it can be
expressed in a short compass and I just
want to allow people to understand that
you don't need to write big long tones
and academic articles in order to make a
sound and important economic point do
you think America is more economically
literate now than when you started
teaching economics I don't know I go
back and forth on that I have some
evidence that it is I mean for example
when I first started teaching economics
we weren't far removed from the 1970s
experience of capping gasoline and oil
prices and today we don't have that
that's a really good thing despite all
the complaints about rising gasoline
prices there's no real serious talk
about capping them is that the result of
greater economic literacy I think so on
the other hand a lot of the stuff that
Obama's doing seems to get rave reviews
he's a skilled politician he keeps doing
and by the way not only Obama but you
know Republicans on Capitol Hill they do
a lot of ridiculous things so I don't
know I think it's probably about the
same your son is 15 years old he's
thinking about college is the future
brighter for him than it was for you
when you were his age yes but I think in
spite of the state rather than because
of the state obviously I've come to see
the market and the free society
generally is actually much more robust
and Hardy than I once believed it to be
I would get rid of you know most of
government I think it's just generally
destructive but I don't believe that it
can easily destroy the spirit of a free
people
and I think there's still enough left of
a free society at this moment to allow
that flourishing of freedom and the
expansion of markets I think that will
continue because of that I think my
son's future is bright but doesn't mean
of course that the government can't grow
even larger and stamp down you know
those those those openings and how can
you make sure for his generation that
they don't go through the economic time
that we're having right now yeah that's
the sixty-four well i would say billion
but given the inflation that that may be
coming 64 trillion dollar question I
just a question I mean it's an issue of
continuing to talk about the importance
of freedom the importance of free
markets and the importance of peace and
individual liberty and rational thinking
that's the only you have to eat infusing
people these ideas there's no other way
you know it's not going to happen by
electing a politician who talks the
right language it only happens by
ensuring that the culture doesn't get
too far away from one that supports it
or at least tolerate sufficient amounts
of freedom and do you think that your
letters are a mechanism for infusing
that or do they act as an IV getting
that rational thinking into the people
who glimpse your words well it then the
small handful of people who read them
yeah I I hope it has some of that but
you know it's it's it's it's one of a
drop in a very large pool of efforts I
don't think my particular drop if you
removed it there'd be any significant
change one way or the other but you know
what reason does what Cato does what my
colleagues G and you do what a lot of
the free market blogs do with a lot of
the state think tanks do scholars all
around the world do publishing houses is
still do you know who publish Milton
Friedman's works and Hayek's these
things add up and into a pool of
scholarship and inspiration for
maintaining enthusiasm for an
understanding of the free society well
thank you for allowing us to dive into
your pool of free-market economics I
hope it's a good swim
half-wits from Donald J Boudreau buy it
immediately when it becomes available
and enjoy his letters for everyone thank
you don thank you